good morning gamers we're continuing a
man of mad Dan that's right because I am
on my honeymoon while you're watching
very a mishap with the barbecue the
whole boat was lit up yeah what what
what's up with the other boat let's ask
what's up with that other boat these
fishing guys came by and ran into the
dive line whatever who cares right
what I would weigh is what you guys find
well we found the plate and it is huge
full of cool stuff unfortunately we did
not leave it as pristine as we could
have what why the dive line actually how
bad
there's no cockpit anymore for starters
well that's just [ __ ] perfect
don't swore she swore it don't like
Stewart oh and it's review time baby
tell me how I did tell me how I killed
it let's hear a gamer you're getting to
know these intrepid adventurers then
Alex and his little brother Brad trying
to swim with the big fish both seem out
of their depth indeed indeed and Julia
the love of Alex's life and he the love
of hers
what about Conrad a bold fellow you
might say well maybe you'd say arrogant
I don't know and there's captain Flitz
plays strong forthright stubborn do I
detect a spark between her and Conrad
who knows anything can happen at me
reassure you you've helped them to make
some decisions they'll value later on
you're doing well yes he likes me
EPIK I thought he would scold me I'm
doing well gamers he heard heard it here
first
any time I do these kind of games
there's always the backseat gamers I
just can't handle it why did he know
looking surprising pretty much what
you'd expect Bradshaw was insane it was
like traveling through time no [ __ ]
well it was like traveling through time
and accidentally ending up in a
dimension where the past is underwater
and like everything particles and sharks
sharks excuse me Julia
I'm gonna need you to stop smiling I
can't keep playing if this goes on I'm
sorry to pause but my brief hey I
thought it was pretty intense wasn't
comrade gonna get us some more beers
after he helped Flis maybe he decided
hey I'll drink some and then he got
drunk and since he was drunk he forgot
to bring it to us
and he just kept on drinking and he
drank all of it sounds like you've had
some experience with this kind of
phenomenon yeah I've been studying it
for you I'll go look for him oh yeah
bracelet lodged in the plane huh I left
it below deck if you want to check it
out
where do I recognize her prom
let's be cherry she there a polar bear
you good
sorry I was just thinking about how
crazy our dive was can you believe what
we just got to experience it was an
experience affected it to be cool but
that was I was like life-changing cool
what an adventure something on this trip
will be memorable what do you what do
you mean nothing boss wants to propose
you're staring I'm doing like a zombie
and now you're all grumbly I'm sorry
just tell me what's up I guess I've just
been worrying about things a lot lately
about us there's nothing to worry about
really I don't I said don't know what
got into you everything's great ok yeah
you're right I'm gonna go find Brad and
Conrad and bliss you mean the others hey
you see my brother or Flitz he's on a
boat I don't know I got distracted let's
go get him sure why don't you get
distracted by him these people are so
weird
[Music]
ok gamers they've been visiting the
Frick chamber Julia haha oh my god [ __ ]
around like that Julia Oh coming from
years oh just get him now
that was epic wasn't it supposed to
storm at 8 o'clock June you guys been
heading back am I the only one
responsible here all right now that
everybody's here let's take a look at
the navigators pad we found maybe we can
figure out why the plane was out here
where'd you put it
it's in your case okay I'll go get it
hey thanks Julian
oh I guess I have to play as Julia now
let's check here first
oh yeah because we can look at the
photos yeah that was fun is this
supposed to be a GoPro 30 meter
waterproof Wow I can look at it here we
go Wow Wow that's a pretty good camera
for low light and Rescue Service Condon
I love pondering on selfie it's me after
making videos alright I think that's it
cool man
I remember playing these type of games
when I was kid obviously very different
because these this genre didn't exist
but like I didn't mean to click on this
by the way just so we're clear I got the
patty yeah thank you
Laurie's let's go get it Oh so he helps
us if you wait that's interesting I
wonder if that changes things just just
looking how much games has improved over
yonder graphics is pretty it's cool to
be playing the games that really push
the forefront on that come here fix it
easy tiger we should get back I remember
playing this game called Egypt there's
something like that and I remember
looking at the grasses I'm like dude
that looks so epic I'm kind of curious
how that looks like now you'll get no
resistance there all right everyone
check it out Manchurian Gold who wants
to find some sunken treasure so what do
you think Adam coordinates those are
coordinates all right maybe the planes
destination you think we could get there
by tomorrow it takes a couple hours if
the weather stays steady but you know
it's gonna come there there was a flight
plan on board that seemed to indicate it
was a rescue plane yeah that makes sense
after the war they turned long-range
bombers into rescue planes and then this
plane must have been shot down cuz it
was riddled with bullet holes
I found one lodged in the fuselage huh
and it was full of life rafts and stuff
gotten shot down before they could
deliver all the rafts there was only one
missing reckless all of you
why use me I told you to leave
everything down there alone oh come on
we've been through this already I'm not
lying I love no Hey oh we're respectful
no you did whatever you wanted whatever
you took it was too much we took a
bullet okay listen you need a chill in
that brick out oh come on no one knows
we've even been down there and I don't
think ghosts can talk you Americans are
all the same huh no respect for anyone
else's traditions I should have never
gone down to that claim in the first
place it's bad luck what is this one a
[ __ ] down there and it makes no
difference but every single thing you
bring back has an essence it's like a
ghost you invite to the surface there we
go
hi
I never thought about it like that you
never think about much of anything well
maybe I never heard about such cool
ghost stories they're not cool ghost
stories not like for fun people drown in
these waters and you have to respect our
resting place damn straight
bread you got a fun ghost story right
sure but you know nothing like what Flis
is talking about
come on tell the ghost so retail LS the
Deo support and less here let's hear it
I want to guess you can spin a good yarn
it's kind of messed up actually scare
away little bro yeah here goes
this story is true it had happened to
right near here in an old lighthouse
that's how you said a good boy yeah true
story
where'd you hear this ah well down by
the dockside I found an ancient here's
here by the way skin like a leather book
eyepatch wooden leg the whole nine yards
and for a dollar he told me his secrets
okay here we go
a lighthouse mister the top and a toll
isolated from the rest of the world of
lone beacon in the night a sailor's
respite the lighthouse keeper would hear
the waves pounding the rocky shore one
misty morning he comes upon a woman
covered in blood she's stumbling down
the beach he hurries to her aid and she
falls into his arms sobbing as he
hurries her back to the lighthouse he
asks where she's from he doesn't waste
any time it's smooth I respect it I
definitely recognize him shush ah woman
answers I live here in the lighthouse
my parents are upstairs right now twists
of course the lighthouse keeper says
that isn't so of course he's lived there
alone for years and the woman becomes
hysterical and it's just her parents are
upstairs so they go to the top of the
lighthouse and they're splayed out on
the floor is a man and a woman brutally
murdered with an axe always an axe I
mean do people even use exes anymore yes
yes they dance cliches and all chopped
up into little tiny giblets have an axe
just like we're Skolnick Oh
that's amping you know sometimes you
have to embellish the facts a little to
get at the deeper truth it's okay
okay so who did it
the woman says he was my husband and she
turns to the closet it says he's in
there is the husband and that's why I've
always been a little weary of marriage
so the lighthouse keeper or shadow a
closet opens the door and sure enough
there's a man inside but he's cut his
own throat
horrified he was closer to see the dead
man's face in the dark closer closer and
he sees it's his own face and then its
eyes bulge out and screams whoa what's
wrong with you super twins nice super
twist
nice one Squire I wasn't scared oh come
on that wasn't scary I think he told it
better last time look good effort oh
wait you've all had your fun we should
all turn in there's some weather heading
our way
uh-huh no no no cuz according to
standard vessel regulation we're all
required one more beer before hitting
the hay what are you a shoes are these
it's standard-issue regulatory
institutional protocol subdivision 1099
where'd you read bed Irish Manor oh so
you found a website that tells you to
drink beer under every circumstance was
man I'm into this website
the storm is coming and you know what
happens when storm comes bad weather
sleep sleep sleep 50s cozy isn't it I
kind of low-key like this
okay oh no this is bad boys this is real
bad
I swear I hit W
[Music]
Hey
all right I really got to do better on
that quick time man hey he's thinking
napping
I really don't want anyone to die
come on I'm ready I'm ready to click
buttons
oh no it's the guy from the boat I
remember him
I've good memory
[Music]
[Music]
ungag okay that works
that pick and see why would get rid of
everyone all right let's talk come on VP
VP VP okay I think so
have you heard of whispering good job
guys
hey hey you can take Hershey's
[Music]
I'm sorry all free that's my watsapp an
attorney
sorry game there's not for finishing
though be hey so have all news bad news
previous don't sailfin to get any worse
bad news is these are kind of maybe the
fishermen I pissed off earlier all god
damn it Conrad afraid just great and the
good news I recognized how was that good
news I thought you were gonna ask the
good news first or sister are they gonna
do to us
get out of here not a danger we should
try not to take her we gotta get untied
like now I agree
I like this yes haha
I was ready this time for check him in
the nose Oni I'll be back for you later
I'm ready I'm ready
nobody knows they're out here it may be
you all alone with us now let's make the
most of it you can go [ __ ] yourself you
piece of [ __ ] I heard the little lady
the big lady epically
[Music]
fight back even though you can't
oh yeah you know how to treat a lady
right oh he did not like that god I'm
good
what is that Oh
I'm sorry please just stop
still down yeah come on listen to Danny
to stop me
read it later Poulos son is their own
son
that's epic
what are you guys there is about the
story like who I be a Geordie filmin I
don't think they necessarily evil
it's too obvious okay okay alright she
found sisters cheap jump
[Music]
oh Jesus Conrad damn Conda not ride em
alright no not Julie I don't know
dipstick dipstick dafuq oh damn snake
God um I don't think they're gonna hit
her they have an influence flush sure
seems to be getting buddy-buddy with him
she's my brother yeah where is he
no I didn't
I'll be sorry all right
chip-chop
don't let me see your hands once we get
Julia back then we could take it my
surprise okay they're coming what are
they doing why are they grabbing each
one of us what do they do to you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
chip-chop
hey hey okay what'd they do to you I'm
fine
they didn't touch me they asked about
our parents what what how much money
they have
to jump
so they just want money that is a make
sense
now we just have to wait and see what
they want to do with us
okay Juliet stop being so morbid they'll
be fine maybe they just want the
barbecue and they saw how lit it was
fairly distinct positive
they don't know about the little brother
actually I just thought about that
it's Area C storms a miles away they
gave me her on a boat maybe we can take
it yeah yeah it's a speed boat he's got
a gun well
at least one of us can get on their boat
it's mobile if you can distract them I
can get on it I don't like this the gun
won't even realize until I'm long gone
seven seconds I can get out through the
window gotta break these off first
chill out they'll hear it we're gonna
break them during the Thunder good call
I'll go through the window and get the
boat you guys distract them Conrad just
stay focused and get to the boat okay
let's do it
this is so exciting did we do it I
thought I think we timed it a little off
there's no way you would break a window
that easy as well but you know whatever
whatever floats your boat am i right
okay this is easy I can definitely do
this doo doo oh hey es war
[Music]
[Music]
drop it Buster Conrad
easy
if listen I got this let me handle it
this will go well I'm sure what are you
doing you idiot
think about what you're doing boy get to
the phone
get out go get trying to kill me order
I'll come on
[Music]
well who knows it might be blessing in
disguise crazy our boat our cheerily
echo line
get these [ __ ] out of here
oh don't shoot Julia please
now wait what this bad no oh my god she
said what are you doing you're in here
penis use a deal you have to can i
replay the entire game
sit down sit no that hurts it hurts me
it hurts when you mess up fam la bouche
de mémoire okay why did a girl
Olson come here
which one of you is going to tell me
about this and jury and or maybe julia
is fine you don't think maybe she's
still alive
we don't know
now she is fine oh thank God I'm here ah
it's okay
oh my God thank you see I told you
optimises adapt overcome
how could we have been so stupid we're
lucky it's not worse could have been
killed
what were you thinking this isn't just
about you Julia oh we could have turned
it around and we wouldn't be in this
mess right now
all right shut the [ __ ] up it's war
there is no harm in just talking you
want to talk yes keep the volume down
all right hey come on we're just passing
the time no big deal
keep quiet I don't know he just said
call him down Gupton says shut your
mouth shut your mouth
okay whoa oh I hit it I hit it and I was
332 oh no yo
that's a smash lack of this video hey
leave her alone
fine he is cooperating
find out the longest um is gonna laugh
you try anything anything s.merinov our
memory consequence
Lucas Milan requesting weather update
yep
hey just requesting any information
about this storm you can give us
it's a little bit hairy out here over
storm coming in from the east
integrate hard should pass through your
coordinates within the hour
sound little stress dude we've looked
know if you need assistance not used to
a little weather freaking job my my
charter has been a little difficult not
exactly going as planned we're starting
to have some serious problems
okay that went good
oh I hit it again and again gamers
[Music]
bye-bye
this is a normal term happens all
standard procedure
[Music]
we might need that boat push it push it
push it push push push push
come on push
then you got to make quick snappy
decisions and I'm not good at those get
it
all right now
[Music]
thanks I guess I know problems you even
know about Brad be hiding somewhere
yeah with a fricassee okay keep a lid on
it it could be our ticket out Brad it
stays hidden better off down there than
with these psychos
oh yeah great he could get killed down
there oh my god
Brad's a big fool he'll be okay and it's
probably better for us to be stays put I
agree I agree
oh my god that's a [ __ ]
Oh
oh this is awesome
everyone's still alive different yeah
yeah yeah yeah they're all alive come on
come on give me praise come on I did
let's get real here gamer it's
recognized gamers one gamer from another
[Music]
no kind-hearted creature I am I'd like
to offer you some forewarning I'd like
you to come absolutely tempted for you
have my interest okay there we will turn
to the bard for inspiration ah yes the
Bard of Venice act 2 scene 7 the Prince
of Morocco pulls a scroll from the eye
of a skull and reads all that glisters
is not gold often have you heard that -
hmm yes anyway now that you've reached a
point of significant distress I presume
you're eager to get back to your story
very well yes a thing everything may not
be entirely as it see
[Music]
probably shouldn't have said that
what is he talking about
curious noises
the boss leper
it's gonna be good man
I mean it seems like the New York
why why would you why would you go on
name I would
come on gamers oh I gotta be ready cuz
it could be a quick time at any point
be
cool they all have the same tattoos
ah man yeah the only order Jesus
what is nope thanks
seems very dangerous I got rather stay
in the boat in the storm right
okay gamer playing as Conrad
names in football
shoes might be good well how could you
say that over all that glisters is not
gold yes I remember
whole place is a floating deathtrap
sorry what are they going here
Julia I can't believe you're alive but
for sure she would night well now we
know I can't freak out you Lily Oh what
is she drop
this is a jump-scare I'm trying to go
that way
no okay I'm pressing forward but I
suppose I hit back yes ok gamer did not
sign up for a trip to creep down that's
a good one with this place making my
hair stick up so far it's gonna jump on
my neck here we go yeah I agree
ok this sorry
go man name
it's doing that thing again starting to
get the hand in the controls look
there's a bunch of Estes
wonder if that's a message the hell do
these [ __ ] followed us
hey for blood
stop there's something blistering
internal memory Arion
people you're covering Patterson card is
tomorrow is sick again conveniently it's
always when it has guard duties in hole
three a first into 3a let's remember
that luckily he didn't see that
excellent
awesome you're going to see okay what's
happening in there jewel is gonna die
Julia pin the dad
hey it's pitch black in here now we see
a light just channeled a maybe French
people not so bad after all
yeah that was so worth
no problem gamers
the hell is this [ __ ] place dude even
those meatheads seem spooked yeah you
think this ship is the material gold we
are in the vicinity of those coordinates
Thanks boats never move over either so
that makes sense we can't just sit
around need a plan we're not exactly in
the best position to be making any moves
second they let their guard down we got
to take advantage of it and get off the
ship yeah and get the bone and bling
blang blang yeah man this whole rust
buckets one tetanus shot from the bottom
of the oh yes we tried to escape didn't
exactly work out we gotta get back to
the boat and find Brad what happened to
him no idea they swiped our distributor
cap gonna be difficult to get anywhere
without it
so can't we just like Hotwire or
something
oh so we can't even wire distributor cap
as [ __ ] knew exactly what they were
doing while those guys are out panning
from entering gold or whatever they
think they're gonna find on this
floating coffin we got to take advantage
and look around for a way out of here
easy easy
alright maybe we can find a painting
that we have what happened here maybe
with the man carrying gold they're
referring to that it's something else
right see I'm smart I'm big
maybe not something maybe they my
carrying all this leavin something real
you only yeah there's next to you come
on alright what up guys
hey baby doll I miss you like crazy
three months until my next jumping into
your mom three months Abbey gnomes some
surely with you guys had a few beers but
don't worry I'll keep everything ready
for you if you catch my drift
how does it work I hope you're that
bollocks pretty blob I know that you can
briefly and I want to keep you safe oh
man well that didn't work that it crime
or Julia alright let's look this is
ripped off yes why was it there's
something about paintings
he clearly heard all our plans by the
way the French are spook the friend
should spook you know it's bad guys mr.
French and then one like French people
sorry French people did you watch it's
going I do like you though if you're
watching this just enjoy the perks of
our all-inclusive cruise nice I found a
letter by the way some guy was writing
it was a little lady back home about all
the ghost crap on the ship ghosts yeah I
mean there aren't really ghosts here
yeah they race right yeah there is let's
hope we don't run across any ghosts got
our hands full already
okay we got one guy complaining about
another guy pretending to be sick so he
could get out of guarding one of the
holes yeah I guess he was kind of a
repeat offender
it sounds like nobody liked it very much
down there so I guess the moral of the
story is stay the [ __ ] away from the
Haunted Cardinals haunted maybe they
just didn't like working there yeah or
maybe there are super ghosts probably
super ghosts that's what super ghosts
ghosts but like 16min it's not a
reference yeah I don't know what you're
saying
super ghosts super goes riding in this
is ten out of ten I just wish I knew
what the fishermen on Planet look those
meatballs are probably just paying for
some donors or meanwhile I said
derogatory she may not even exist I mean
what if they don't find anything then
we're [ __ ] so what do we do way I see
it we got two options we sneak out where
we stay here and fight simple as that
yeah sneaking out is a better option I
agree but I just don't know how we're
gonna do it okay well we're not gonna do
anything from in here we need to keep
looking around and try to find a way up
all right yeah catch you later
oh my god
found it like I found your mama on the
flip-flop over here your mama on a bleep
bar
I can get kicked in easier than I can
kick in your mom okay sorry
[Music]
my kicking it bro maybe we need hey
swore we can use a chair I would use a
chair
did we look here do you think this is
useful in any way I don't think sizes
classes what can you use glasses for in
a survival scenario well you can make
fire within sunlight but I don't think
there's any Sun that was a very awkward
moment can we all agree in there cool
bro I was trying but like you lose
freaked me any luck I can get it open
hey we're gonna use Juliet and then
throw her right
maybe we can mend it open and get out of
here what are you talking about exactly
no we're a bit like this we're gone yeah
it can't be words wherever elites it
can't be worse than you I'm gonna just
smash through this wall oh yeah sure
big man on campus hey Juliet so much
watching stretching this is gonna be
loud yeah okay
Conrad you do it all right all right I
can do that
shiver me timbers I'm warning you I am
an American citizen you really
hey work each and every one of you
personally can stop now
fine now I will just be quiet and turn
off the light
they never friend of mind us we are
killing it absolutely destroying it and
I feel good about it I haven't missed a
single quick time of it use that as a
weapon ah yeah damn I love with it done
the place come on I might be vintage
it's gotta be some stairs around here
sell it on eBay for a couple of bucks
you know I'm going in here no frickin
way
Oh extra guard duty regulation due to
special security precaution on this
mission that up the soda Carter no
talking no playing games no smoking
alcohol no gambling alright that's fine
don't care hey guys sorry about that
just had to do something for no reason
at all
oh god I lost them oh hello chip-chop
yeah this is not creepy at all
dude that's Lana's gonna be so smelly
man there's the mystery this surprise
that wasn't a jump scare there
I can't move we just I think we're I
can't move and then I click and it goes
back there we go
hello Swedish man here
ja blahblahblah ah you try to be nice
you try to be polite they did that trick
they did their old Silent Hill you think
it's coming and then you know the locker
no just me and then it comes on your way
out you know I'm talking about you over
school of veteran minecraft trying to
move it here doesn't want to let maybe
there's something here then no guess
I'll walk all the way around then video
game be like burrow
well I'm glad I did that just to get
jumpscared
there was a pretty heavy jump-scare
scene on solo and I remember and I don't
what excuse me
I just want to know what my crazy how
could they all just vanish and b-ball
other stuff what is it what is your
thing
oh no this is where the spook comes
spook warning this place is [ __ ]
dwarf
[Music]
not as scary as minecraft but man that
still give me the creeper leave us you
know I'm saying
creeper leave us now we didn't check out
the other place in the beginning but
it's alright don't want to walk all the
way back what do we get okay that thing
is a little in the way because now I
have to do that again really
you click it once right and then you
have to hold it down and then spin it
and he just puts it down automatic I'm
confused
alright let's keep going Julia Oh see I
would try and get a weapon there's so
many stuffer laying around here right
just like a metal pipe or anything see
if I was in this situation I would want
to represent live yeah what is that what
it's a little rat is 90 you course
bacteria things are relatively on intact
here
right
well yes perfect alright whatever guy
what's the premonition doesn't really
help us at all
but you know giving you take you
flipping you flaunt you pee and your
drop all right it rhymes it that's wide
science everyone knows
this is really creepy
Oh
I think I see something someone's gonna
fall down I'm calling it turn off the
flashlight you dim flicking flop come on
Julian don't mess this up for me oh yeah
there might be quick time I'm ready
20 steps ahead
what is that oh that's the flip-flop
that we need for the boat
conveniently players down he must've
known we I'm happy telling you now I can
do this
I'm gonna go get it I like that girl
now's our chance waymond alright quick
time time you've had watch my back
no yes do watch away s-sorry keep it
come on let's get a gamer's that looks
very dangerous and I would not recommend
doing how she did it
[Music]
I think I made the right choice
come on
I feel like she's so badass she could
take him out Oh what
okay quick time finder damage is taking
place
where are the others I couldn't even do
anything about that no way I did she say
don't want this bus should keep on thank
you
she was up well before what was I
supposed to do there I couldn't do
anything that was like inevitable if I
hide she would have been taking the new
engine that's so strange
gotta keep our distance it's faster all
right well we don't seem to care
others don't want any characters to die
this episode that's all I need
Julia can go it's alright
I'm taking over here four barrels that
was funny actually you know at least I
get to wear shoes wait a minute we've
been here before
that's the girl in the kitchen am i loud
we definitely have not been in the
kitchen before Dido cool
I made six but it has been cooking
something good for yourself
yeah Nance I'm a truthful guy what can I
say
see if you remember that one next time
Juliet what are they cooking Oh dad
looks very short Matt was ill as if you
know your way around the kitchen
oh that's clearly I don't just messing
around
yeah seems like appropriate time to be
messing around absolutely don't see a
problem at all
Juliet get out of my way you block my
path one more time Julia and next
QuickTime event these fingers think we
gotta go through here okay Oh painting I
really want to check that out
oh you can run my shift I keep
forgetting business gypto all right
another painting
oh no what what ah okay well we know
he's alive
we also know he's gonna die so there sir
win some lose some scenario shouldn't he
be affected by that scene that didn't
seem like it bother him I know I saw
something he was moving in the shadows
rats probably just rats that's all it
was
[Laughter]
alright Juliet gotta be this way okay
no this isn't working for me 100 crappy
chapels not my scene you know it is
great it's gross
and it's crappy gotta get out of your
tooth sweet and we got to find Fliss
yeah okay so can we just get the [ __ ]
out then swore it's a Indian burial
ground
very dangerous all right we can check
them all let's check this one Brian we
got a name on this guy and what are they
even doing here I don't think stuck in a
ghost ship for all eternity sounds like
a good plan
here's where they're from or where
they're going they're dead and we're not
so let's keep it that way gamers I am so
sorry but I have to end this episode
here my food is about to arrive and I
want to eat it's much like if you want
another episode and I'll make sure it
comes right next to your baby girl boy
thing epic see you guys next one bye bye
well you haven't tried to persuade me
later at citizen e after 50 million
outros much go just now it's still
relevant just down a bit